Mag jouw werkgever je thuis komen controleren
als je je hebt ziek gemeld?
Nee dit mag eigenlijk nooit.
Jouw gezondheid is namelijk privé
en wordt beschermd door de wet.
Dingen die te maken hebben met jouw gezondheid
mag je werkgever ook niet registreren
Als een werkgever jouw ziekte wil controleren
dan moet dat met een bedrijfsarts
of met behulp van een arbodienst.
Wel moet je
als zieke werknemer houden aan het verzuim reglement.
Dit is een lijst met afspraken die als het goed is
aan het begin
van je arbeidsovereenkomst
hebt gekregen van je werkgever
hier kunnen dingen in staan
over
wanneer je bereikbaar moet zijn voor een bedrijfsarts
en wanneer je gebeld kan worden door je werkgever.
Met een werkgever
die dus jouw ziekte wil controleren
en bij jou opeens op de stoep staat
heb je dus niks te maken.